this episode of lifeline is brought to
you by original grain
uh you can use code lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e
uh at originalgrain.com to get 30 off
the most and i don't say this lately the
most fashionable watches made from
reclaimed whiskey barrels beer barrels
exotic exotic woods and uh even taylor
guitars and look dude uh you're
guaranteed to find something that fits
your style matt's a ring guy sweetie's
ring yeah he found something to fit his
style i love this ring and check this
out i opened up this you know i'm like a
i like beef i like beef on my wrist
right here dude that's chunk i took it
out i was like okay it's beefy it's
chunky i like it makes me feel like a
man i put it on looks top-notch over the
tattoo and guess what dude he's got the
sunglasses on did they make sunglasses
too
somebody asked me that and i left for 30
minutes and when i was done i said i'm
wearing them baby yeah you are and they
look good on you thanks dude look how
cool i look in the car with the beef up
like that dude yeah
originalgrain.com 30 off of the most
fashionable watches if you use the code
lifeline um they also make great wedding
rings sunglasses apple watch bands made
from the same sustainably sourced
materials make sure you use code
lifeline for 30
off
originalgrain.com
to support the podcast look at these
look at this one you got the gold one if
you're a you know what i mean you got
the gold one if you're a uh what do you
call it a gold guy a guy boss right
there it's got some gold on it
it's got some gold on it you like that
it's right there you get 30 off you use
lifeline or the understated dude yeah
it's on this class that's classic if you
like understated
watches
or beef watches original grain has them
all 30 off use the code lifeline um it's
good stuff and guess what if you're a
guitar guy which i don't play the guitar
but this one comes with a guitar pick
forget it strumming
okay you know what i mean
lifeline code original crane
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
so we're going we started yeah we
already started oh okay we're started
yes so british to say it that way what
did i say we're started
we are started
you should have said we did we start
that's the american version of that i
mean we started is still the right way
okay you can wait so we agree way too
close on that yeah it's all good that's
that's that's very confrontational
that's what you did this is lifeline
episode two dude we finally made it to
episode two how do you know if we were
gonna
um and also
[ __ ] smash hit dude yeah it's big
yeah we're a smash hit so that's it and
we're counting on you to keep
doubling it with the views doubling it
and doubling it until they kill me did
you know that so irish doubling it
uh i did know that two bucks said that
you know why i knew two bucks said yeah
because you say it all the [ __ ] times
double it we gonna double it and we're
gonna keep doubling it until they kill
me although he said that n word but i
can't so it's fine yeah you definitely
can't but he said it nor should you
desire it but you can't do it no i don't
you mean just because nobody wants right
right right
in this room anyway um so yeah so too
much traffic driving down here right
just before we start for you i know but
not for you but here's the thing about
living in l.a and it's going to piss you
off and frankly i don't care wow you so
many disclaimers you already live you
live in l.a
oops i know bro that's why i did it out
of the microphone i was crinkling it
it's fine you already live in la you've
lived in l.a for so long
you you can only complain about la
traffic
within like the first few years of
living in la because otherwise
it's your own fault because you didn't
take traffic into account
now i'm pissed yeah i knew and it's fine
but here's the deal though
it's i don't normally ever drive
downtown
well you've driven downtown a few times
for this i know but this is and i used
to live downtown and used to come
downtown when i lived here i know that
but this traffic was worse
yay dude he figured it out and we both
agree on it and that's fine
dude we agree it was different you
pissed off the dog the dog bark but it's
fine dude because it was too much what
you were doing i know but i didn't even
hear it because i was in my head going
yay and it's oh no because you were
being too [ __ ] loud is why you did
that dog was cheering with me because
you know that the traffic is absolutely
not and it was specifically worse today
great no it wasn't dude la traffic is
always bad stop clapping it's not well
okay it's usually bad this was
horrendous [ __ ] yeah dude
stop doing that but it wasn't it
deserves a round of applause
you know what i do deserve
that hoodie no it's mine
i know it's mine you can't have it i
deserve it i really like it it's yellow
and it pops and you're trying to
basically you're trying to subtly take
the visual visual away
i did do that yeah but but you're trying
to subtly take it away from me by using
a bright color by not saying look at me
did you get paint on it or it came like
that no this came like that dude you
know that i didn't know that you think i
was outside just well actually if i
thought more about it you never picked a
[ __ ] paintbrush in your life
dude that's not true
okay what's the last thing you painted a
picture of a self-portrait in eighth
grade yeah okay well then you don't
paint
okay well
you thought it was outside what is this
outside with the paint
who paints like that jackson pollock in
me no he didn't do that he stood over
the canvas and did like this he didn't
like whip it who's that guy who does the
who's the the [ __ ] guy who sells
like the worst [ __ ] now he's like a pop
artist he did the um oh uh drake's album
darien or something oh i don't know
they're gonna say damien hurst
sounds like a singer-songwriter that
would be damien hearst i don't i don't
know what that is yeah so he does stuff
like like this and then sells it
literally for millions of dollars yeah
it's that's nothing but i didn't do that
to this anyway right damien did damon
came over and did that damn her shirt no
no no no no that if i if it did dude i'd
be set for life this [ __ ] i could sell
for millions of dollars he's that big
he's huge do it damn yeah okay and
people think he's a con artist you
should be a con artist and say damian
hurst did that to that shirt and sell it
for three million dollars on ebay
don't think about that no what did you
think about no i didn't think about it
you shouldn't even know it had [ __ ]
paint splotches on it
till i said it yeah do you look at what
you wear before you put it on no i go by
feeling i go by feeling i feel the i
feel the article of clothing that's why
it's so stylish well that's why you
always look the way you do and that
explains a lot and i feel like that i
feel like with that hoodie you know what
i feel about it i feel like it's mine so
bullets i deserve it
that's not your feelings i deserve it
yes the traffic's too long and he
deserves the hood that is the most
annoying thing you could ever ever
[ __ ] do dude that is the most
annoying thing you can ever do
imagine a lawyer doing it and yeah i had
so much evidence yeah so i'm sure the
jury will acquit him yeah i would never
win a single [ __ ] case i don't know
man in times like these
no that's nothing okay that is nothing
well last episode you got mad at me for
saying uh the heart wants what the heart
wants that is so what you just said is
even more enough what did i say that was
nothing i forgot what did he say
about how times like in times like these
it means nothing you don't need to
preface that ever in times like these
you only need to preface it if you're
talking about other times
yeah yeah but no about the own the time
you're in you never need to say in times
like these because everything anybody
says in a time that you're in it's
implied that it's true in times like
these you don't need to preface it when
it's already in times like these by
saying in times like these okay
i understand what you're saying because
it's true but that's not true because
times because that's it's like saying
are you kidding me
now
no
well i can just add now and make a point
but i did are you kidding me it's not
like you know dude if a lawyer came out
and was like [ __ ] doing all sorts of
really great presenting right yeah and
[ __ ] cross-examination up the [ __ ]
you know just leaving people up shit's
creep without a paddle and just [ __ ]
slam it and he goes like this yeah i had
so much evidence yay
yeah i proved it yay i'm sure the jury
will acquit him yay you don't think that
he that would be not only would he get
away with it that would be a good thing
that's fine but you're wrong
and that's crazy i would not help so any
lawyer and any client would fire would
be right to and would just fire that
lawyer if i was on the [ __ ] thing i
would stand up right with him
on the jury wherever i was [ __ ]
mistrial
if you clapped along with the lawyer
mistrial okay then you'd have to start
over again which isn't necessarily a bad
thing but that's true um so i actually
wondered that why people don't because
the mistrial is
good for the defendant you know yeah why
don't
they just take their like pants yeah and
start shooting on the floor
and the lawyer with his suit on with his
pants all crinkled up just like whoops
yeah mister yeah walk first i bet
this'll do it i'm doing a mistrial
i uh i just found a loophole in the
legal system there you go so during time
like z that's crazy nope um so we had a
great episode the first episode it was
really fun uh we gave a bunch of amazing
advices we really did yeah i did you're
right um and uh you know we can
basically just
it's not we're not therapists no we're
not therapists we're definitely not
there but it's entertainment
and entertainment and this is comedy
comedy podcast and we're rip roaring
should we go we want to want to start it
off now let's start it off dude the way
he said it yeah like
yeah yeah gonna crash and burn all right
has nothing has nothing for us here we
go hey guys um to get straight to it um
i was to have i had to have a debate
with a friend of mine and uh we're
trying to settle whether or not um we
should entertain small talk and i told
him about this person that i met on an
elevator uh go to an international
school so it's normal for people to ask
where you're from
uh and i got to ask that but i was going
down one floor so i just said you know
we don't have to do this because i
didn't want to start explaining and then
the door opens and you have to do that
awkward goodbye and you know so but i
can't think of a way of saying that
without it being rude because my friend
thinks it's rude
so uh do you guys think it's rude to
just say it as it is and is there a way
to say that without sounding rude i can
think of it anyway i love you guys
well that guy doesn't seem like a rude
guy he's not rude so if he can say it
and get away with it then it's fine he's
talking about how being in the elevator
and somebody's saying well first of all
how many
put it this way if the building is sky
high right and you get into a an
elevator and someone's there and they
say hey how's it going you're both going
up you might be on a hundredth floor
empire state building okay but if the
building is like eight or floors less
and you actually say hey how's it going
and you decide to start small talk with
somebody in an eight-story [ __ ]
building yeah you're a piece of [ __ ]
right we can agree on that well i think
there's because if it's how's it going
that's fine but he's didn't he say
somebody asked him where he's from oh
that yeah but that's terrible though
that's no good because then you gotta
get in places where you're from yeah no
nobody wants you you're gonna wind up in
the other guy's apartment if it's like a
[ __ ] i think that's rude of that
person to through do that almost
look i think the answer to your question
is
as long as you're not being rude it's
not rude but okay
what does that mean though it means as
long as you're not like look there's a
way to do it
no he just did like that that's rude of
[ __ ] fine you and the horse you wrote in
on
but no i'm actually i'm saying the thing
that he said we don't have to do that oh
right
he said we don't have to do that right
right which could i guess it could be
it's a pretty rude
thing to say yeah if that's like if
you're trying to shut it down right
what's the non-rude way thing to say i
don't uh speak english only words i know
are these words i'm saying right now no
no no no no extra words but all of these
words i'm saying and also golf and shoes
but that's it and that's it
but you also if you don't want to lie
what's the right way to to shut it down
if i'm in an elevator and i and it's
eight stories up
well whatever yeah okay no it's
different if it's a hundred stories
maybe maybe it's not rude to say hey
where are you from you're both stuck in
a [ __ ] box for a hundred floors i
don't like where you're from in general
though well yeah that's annoying well no
but they asked him because he walked in
and he was from like with the south
african-american because he had an
accent you know they must get that
which is another thing clear your accent
up don't be like that where does he live
no no no if he lives in america do an
american accent which is you know
there's no reason to ask a stranger
where they're from just because they
have an accent that is [ __ ] annoying
interesting rule i like that rule
wow where are you from but what if
you're really interested still
wow uh no i don't i don't i don't know i
mean if you have like a if you have a
fur if you think you know where it's
from
right south africa south africa no not
that if you ask and you have like more
to say about where you think the
accent's from maybe that's okay but
we're getting away from it
it's not rude i don't think to be like
we don't need to do that but i'll tell
you what a lot of people are going to
think you are [ __ ] rude and there's
no way around that that's true but also
people are going to think you're rude no
matter what you do exactly because like
if he's looked at me and said if i say
oh yeah where you from he said we don't
have to do this and they hit the thing i
would laugh yeah right right but i don't
think it's true
most people would think that's rude for
sure i don't and you don't but a lot of
people would be like that's [ __ ] rude
yeah we don't need to do that that's
like people think that's condescending
yeah and they're like but what about
pleasantries they go like that but they
got to work on their own [ __ ] just be
you like the [ __ ] last one be
unapologetically you you could do a spin
move if you want when you leave the
elevator okay you can't have spin move
be every every piece of advice that you
give be do a spin move i think that okay
i i know that but i think spin moves
like you're barry sanders
that's awesome okay so you're not rude
don't worry about other people and
honestly if people think you're being
rude for just speaking your truth and
not being aggressive about it yeah then
that person is a hater and if you have
haters you're winning so there you go
good job okay okay stop dude definitely
stop clapping all right so we all agree
on the traffic thing in this here we go
want to go to another one let's do
another one
i'm glad we could help these people hey
crystal matt my name is caroline um i
first wanted to say true baby and life
always rips
um i think i have a good one for you so
i recently went through a breakup
the person that i broke up with set very
clear boundaries
for
like how they wanted the breakup to go
they were like don't like post a lot on
social media about how much fun you're
having now that you're single
um
don't like hang out with these people
too much if it means that i can't that
kind of stuff
but then they're not respecting those
boundaries that they set for me
they're posting things all the time
they're hanging out with people all the
time
how do i approach that in a way that's
still respectful to what they want while
not compromising what i want
i got thanks for the submission i got a
really good piece of advice for you
that person does not deserve her respect
because
he is asking
her not to do something and then he goes
and does it you that's like
you have [ __ ] car blocks to not do
any of the [ __ ] he asked for he's saying
hey don't he has all these [ __ ] rules
for her yeah he's being a bit of a nazi
about it and he doesn't have to [ __ ]
follow them then why does she have to
follow them because of being a nazi
about it but don't
nazis don't believe in me that's a bit
much i'm just saying he's not being a
[ __ ] nazi i'm just saying he's being
a piece of [ __ ]
and i don't think you need to respect
him at all piece of [ __ ] is not a bit
much but nazi is i think not correct
piece of [ __ ] is way less bad than nasty
because nazi is the worst possible thing
this is what you will be doing on the
break up ground rules you will not be
posting with friends that we both have
too much you will not be having a good
time too much on social media right but
it wouldn't surprise me if he wasn't he
was okay see now so when i do you don't
need to be driven to be a nazi though i
know that but most hardcore nazis aren't
for sure most true og notes he's got a
people and it's like so we break up so
good we break up good
no posting on social media if you will
be sucking dicks you will not be letting
me know about it
okay if you will be sucking songs you
will not be knowing about i will not be
knowing about this
if you will be taking this in the back
you will not be telling me about this
please
right right okay but what about the
advice though if you will be dating what
what do you think what should she do
yeah well i want to know i'm gonna go
deeper into this i want to know did he
set up the rules for the both of them or
just her
either way it's nazi like activity
because here's the deal if he's like
these are so rules we are going to go by
and then he goes back on on his it was
all propaganda so he could just get what
he wants but it's very nazi-ish
propaganda but if if he says you will
not be doing this and i will be doing
this that's also very nazi-ish right
right because very controlling right i
think that this guy honestly in a few
years you're gonna realize that this guy
was a joke i don't know much about this
guy i don't know his side of his story
at all but i have the feeling
if he told me his side of the story it
would be in a german accent so honestly
i think that you should probably just
either do what you want and why can't
you just block him or hide him block
each other she's being too nice
she's being too right now she should not
he's
already basically
given you license to do whatever the
[ __ ] you want because he gave you rules
that he doesn't whether he plans on
following them
himself or planned on following
themselves said he was going to follow
them too or made them just for her
that's even [ __ ] worse
either way [ __ ] this guy do whatever you
want post whatever you want do whatever
you want [ __ ] see whoever you want
date whatever you want hang out with
your friends whenever you want [ __ ] that
guy pretty harsh and i think that we
should just kind of make it a little bit
of a softer thing and say he's probably
a nazi and you know what that's not
softer uh he's a nazi and um
also
you know just be careful be wary right
because these guys are in trouble and
i'm just saying you don't want yourself
you're adding your knots
right you don't want you're adding the
nazi parts
you don't want your skin to end up being
a lampshade right now that would have
been great if it was not interrupted but
now it seems a little bit dark and
shitty when i was doing it it was going
to be great and have a great payoff
it did seem dark and shitty i will grab
right that's because we stopped there so
it's my fault yes a thing you said was
dark and shitty and it's [ __ ] mine
because i go
and it was gonna be
bam home run but it was
and then you came and then i had to be
like
no i don't like anything that you're
saying okay but i do like her and i i'm
on her [ __ ] side and i [ __ ] do not
like that guy
okay and i think you should
maybe even specifically do what he said
not to because wow dude he's being such
a piece of [ __ ] you're she's being such
a piece of he's being such a piece of
[ __ ] to her you don't know his side of
the story dude she seems very sweet she
seems very sweet this guy could come on
our show next week and be like listen
you know it's very upsetting because
what has happened was she was basically
um
making uh uh she was basically making
the the
the relationship seem like it wasn't i
was a very nice guy i would always buy
her things okay but we're not hearing
his side right we're only hearing her
side so okay gives a [ __ ] about his side
my whole problem with it is she was
obviously flexing her watch
and in the [ __ ] thing like this yeah
no i liked that watch yeah
no she's she's pr i'm i'm playing and
he's probably you know
do what you want yeah if you're broken
up do what you want do what you want
anyway that's a good point yeah he
shouldn't have made [ __ ] rules [ __ ]
him the whole i don't know turtles all
the way down [ __ ] him all the way down
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] wow i don't like this
guy wow okay and i'm glad you broke up
with him okay cool was it worth it
okay let's bad guy guys going to grow up
to be a [ __ ] dictator you know it
yeah he's a bad guy okay yeah all right
next
yo oh it's the dude from the last time
the guy okay play it i was going
his hair is different he's trying to
disguise himself well let me tell you
something right now we don't we have not
seen these videos beforehand we've
decided not to see the videos beforehand
because we think it gives more authentic
visceral reactions and uh we we go with
our gut immediately yeah and that's yeah
good well we had the option
producers first do you want to see him
yeah no we don't say no so okay so let's
play this guy this is a follow-up i
suppose unless he's a twin play over
again yo
on the french girl situation wow told
her i was going to france she was like
oh wow that's so cool that's awesome
i told her about the drawings too and
she goes
yeah it's nice honestly but a little
weird because i have a boyfriend and
we're probably never going to see each
other again oh anyways cried about it
had a good night's sleep
it was so definitive and matter of fact
that i can't be in denial and it feels
healthy um i'm still going to france
because i'm enrolled in school there but
it's six hours away from her cities so
no stalking um thanks for keeping
absolutely [ __ ] real
and giving me the benefit of the doubt
and being hilarious peace
broke down in [ __ ] tears for 35
minutes after the video even right after
the video dude i wonder what happened
after the [ __ ] call yeah my favorite
[ __ ] part was got a good night's
sleep
yeah you know cried my [ __ ] ass off
got a good night's sleep got up you know
dude unreal dude
god good night sleepy
eat a great breakfast like dude you know
got to work out in played some ball with
the homies yeah dude so he didn't let me
let's just go first of all let me do
this for good measure
knew this was going crazy
here's the thing man and i wanted to
talk about this because this has been
sitting with me since last episode last
episode this guy said he's been trying
to move for a girl that he talks to
every few months now matt's a couple
months a couple months yeah right a
couple months i did say he misspoke you
said he missed poke and you kind of
[ __ ] you didn't bully me into it but
made me feel bad you're like be nice be
nice that's on you though
all right dude but you said make make
sure
you know he might have misspoke so i
said okay yeah maybe he did misspoke and
i'm driving home after the [ __ ]
podcast and i'm like i don't think he
did misspeak and i feel bad that i said
that and i was right dude yes i was
right man but you didn't misspeak and he
was just if we rolled the tape right now
the truth is you said i think you
misspoke you said that you said it first
i did say it first but you said it i
know because you kind of i don't want to
see you bullying me you're saying it's
my fault it is your fault no it's
[ __ ] not dude
here's the deal to assume he misspoke is
absolutely correct because
he crazed yeah okay sure so you don't
assume someone it's [ __ ] crazy but
why don't you know somebody's crazy when
you [ __ ] see them and he seemed
normal he seemed his hair was nice he
was like looked like yeah he looks like
a good guy i wish him all the best and i
think that's obviously good and he's
going to find a romantic partner he
obviously isn't crazy dude you know what
i mean i'm saying he crazed but i'm not
saying right right really actually crazy
that's why i say he crazy because we
actually thought he was crazy we
wouldn't even have him on the podcast we
would feel bad you craze is different
than crazy right right and he also has
um he also asked us to roast him right
he did the first video yeah he said
roast us so roast me throws to us you
know he's crazy schizophrenia more than
once
yeah do it and um so he uh ah so robin
williams what i just did so um
so anyway um that's good he seemed like
he figured it out and i like we know
what i like about this guy what don't
point at me before if he is crazy or not
if he's crazy you're crossing you're
crossing my you're encroaching yeah
we're gonna have a [ __ ] problem
you know what the you know what i like
about this guy what do you like his
craziness
comes into play and then it's
okay that's not what it is on to the
next on to the next crazy right
my concern is he's not gonna learn the
lesson he's gonna be crazy again he is
oh he is okay on to the next on on to
the next drawing pictures on to the next
on on to the next on to the next he's
just gonna alter the drawings for the
next person
he's like [ __ ] i already got i already
got 71 of them i don't want to start
over yeah dude what
just facetiming with her crying what do
i do with all these drawings yeah
[ __ ] drawings of like [ __ ] of her
naked just tits spilling out looking
like salvador dali whoops went too far
anyway but
what i think in general yeah i'm
concerned he's not going to learn a
lesson moving forward
and uh i'm i'm i'm wondering why he let
himself
think it was a good idea to move there
oh boy
crazy
yeah i mean there's no yeah no
accounting for a craze people try to
[ __ ] act like there's a thing you can
do to help crazy but there's not unless
you're a medical doctor right but he's
probably not actually crazy but
yeah dude look man this is how it is and
this is good that it's happening to him
at a younger age because it you know it
helps him you know get ready for life do
you think he is 23
22. yeah i'm bad at that i don't know
how old anybody is ever yeah
i just found out that harrison ford is
32.
no i think you're misinformed nope i i
think so he's 32.
well when did star wars come out when he
was no see no see this says this math
doesn't work because even if he was one
no
no
whatever agreed to disagree but uh so
yeah so we appreciate you checking back
in and that's a cool thing we can do on
this podcast i like that yeah i didn't
know we were uh that was going to be a
thing yeah but i guess it is
so yeah the advice now is to just keep
on moving and uh try to be a little bit
less
craze
in every relationship even if it's not a
relationship and you think it is check
in with someone else to make sure that
it's because he was making us think that
he they didn't even do the harassment
technically he checked in with us
did they even hook up
marco
they didn't even hook up
and he was going to move the [ __ ] were
you buddies now i don't know no he he
said he never did he said he never
hooked up with the girl oh on the video
yeah no oh okay
okay so there we go
he never he never hooked up with the
girl we could do a whole episode on this
guy so he sent a video oh okay truth
comes out he sent a video he also wrote
in it he said it's in one of those
things i don't know if he said it oh he
wrote okay i also wrote in and he said
it's clear
it's probably clear to you now that we
didn't hook up okay so they didn't even
hook up and he was going to move
countries for her all good
okay yeah that's bad okay so anyway feel
free though bro it's hard out there love
life that's tough that's tough but
unrequited love is tough unrequited love
never knew what that is i hear it all
the time never knew it you don't know
what it is nope
well now you do right you've gleaned
what it is it's when somebody loves
somebody but the other person doesn't
love them back correct knew it
but you know the point is you didn't
know it didn't have to look it up but
knew it
felt it okay you know what i mean like
you're with fourteen you're [ __ ] 40.
i'm 42 40 you're 42
bad brother wow such a bad brother i
know how old you are i know how you are
you don't you're saying harrison ford
all right okay you wanna do next one
what is this okay oh this is a written
one oh this is going to be sick i want
to read it out loud i have a great
speaking voice but you can want me to
read it i'll read it
hello gentlemen an evil villain
i grew up in a super religious family
and as i've gotten older i've realized
that organized religion is not for me
great i've felt a lot freer since i've
broken away from religion but my family
is still very religious and involved
with the church and i'm finding it more
and more difficult to dance around the
subject at family gatherings
i figured i could get some sage advice
from my cult leader and pastor m diesel
about how i should approach this
sensitive issue do i continue to play
along for the sake of peace or do i
speak my true beliefs so that i can be
more real with my family love you guys
and thanks for years of entertainment
that's so we totally get by the way why
you didn't do a video because then your
family would see it and you would be and
the whole advice is what should you let
them know or not know so i get it yeah
that's a that's that is hard i mean
that's a real hard thing to do i feel
very strongly about just religion and
belief in general but
you believe in jesus christ our lord and
savior yeah exactly
um i i
i wish i i wish i knew a little bit
better about like
what
how hardcore they might be yeah sort of
like straying well assume they're really
hardcore
i mean he's obviously struggling with it
there will obviously be a huge rift if
he says something yeah okay is it worth
that or is it worth sucking it up and
just being like my parents are going to
die one day i don't want to disappoint
them
i think you got to be honest wow i think
you got to be honest and i think and i
think here's the deal i don't think you
should come out and be like listen mom
and dad no spin moves no spin moves
necessaries yeah do you would you
recommend a spin move on this one no not
with the face okay so i think what you
would do
i don't think you need to like make it a
whole sit down
i don't think you need to make it a
whole moment but i think if
act the way you want to act and then if
it comes up if they bring it up whatever
then you tell them maybe bit by bit
again i don't think you need to make a
whole [ __ ] sit-down moment of it like
an intervention or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah making it less dramatic as
possible exactly just be like i'm grown
out of it or or i'm thinking maybe i'm
i'm feeling like this you don't need to
be like i don't believe in the [ __ ] you
believe and [ __ ] you
yeah you can just be like look that's
what i'm saying no spin moves right i'm
getting a lot like i'm starting to maybe
think i think other things like and if
they don't want you to
i guess pun sort of intended because i
realized it go with god on it then
that's on them but i i think if you
start out like look i'm sort of starting
to expand my
mind a bit and starting to think maybe i
don't believe in this maybe i believe in
that whatever there's a way to make it
soft drop the bomb but not
so much destruction maybe at maybe at uh
like family dinner you're just eating
and you know everyone's having a good
time
so this jesus guy huh
you really that all are you all really
that all into it i'm just saying there's
no proof but you know what i mean you
could just do that
i'll just say where's the proof and
then we could we could move on and then
i'll agree with it so some of the proof
and then it's all good so but the
chicken is really good you know how you
do that yeah i mean what if you did that
and you realized no one actually
believed they were just waiting for one
person to say that and they were like oh
[ __ ] thank god mark you finally said
something
that would be uh yeah it could go yeah
you don't know how you could go that way
you don't know how it's going to go but
my point is it also it here's another
thing that i'm going to raise because
i'm very smart i'm going to raise this
point
it depends really how old your parents
are
like you keep like bringing something up
like if you're if he's
15 right and his parents are 40 yeah
that's a long time those parents are
going to be alive you can work through
issues but if you're if they're 80 and
he's 45 he's the same age as harrison
ford if they're 80 and he's 40 yeah
their parents might croak in two years
it's not worth it to leave him [ __ ]
shitty in the past two years thinking
that their son's gonna be in the very
tips of hell
uh okay but he
or she i guess do we know if this i
don't know okay i don't know i'm sexist
he or she uh they're gonna
have
to live longer
yeah than their parents and maybe
they would have liked to have been known
by their parents more maybe they're
going to live with the idea of well what
if i told them i should have told them
live my true life because it is a big
[ __ ] deal i mean what if this person
has to go to [ __ ] church and like
pray and say grayson they really don't
want to it's not it doesn't feel good to
have to go along with some religious
[ __ ] when you don't believe in it i feel
like really yeah i know but like also
everyone seems like it's like everyone
is like complaining about everything and
all you got to do is like sit at church
for an hour and be like oh yeah you know
every week though yeah but it's like
you're with your parents who gives a
[ __ ] if it's nice for them they're just
like cool yeah oh yeah and on the third
day uh
you know what i mean they're just
sitting there they just got to do that
it's not like they got to do manual
labor and build a [ __ ]
church they just got to be like
oh yeah yeah and also with you
i think you should tell him but i think
he or she should tell him i think he
should test the waters
at least at the outset not to drop the
bomb and just be like i don't believe in
this [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] but to just
sort of ease into it uh oh what i got
the uh [ __ ] absolute this goes deeper
than what we're even talking about right
now okay church needs to be more fun
yeah well i agree with that that's it
dude you've been to a black church i
haven't but i've seen it on [ __ ]
racist movies and dude it's like they go
or whatever they don't [ __ ] they
don't do that
they don't sing that [ __ ] song that's
for sure
why
why did you do that you know whatever it
is dude what's that [ __ ]
you're doing it again it's the same
thing you're doing dude or what okay i
know they do that one where it goes
that's not something either i'm sorry
but you're not singing real songs
that's not they do no oh my lord and
then they do this
and if you're doing this
and then what happens is they do a few
ones loud like that and then they get
quiet and they go oh my lord okay and
then someone speaks and they're like
jesus i would like to let you know that
yada yada and everyone in the background
so do you think he should talk to his
pastor but what i'm saying is and then
that guy finishes and he's like and
that's what i mean and then they go oh
my lord they get louder again have you
seen glory so the point is
make church more fun maybe you can
involve him in the way that you never
even thought you could right and then
he's sitting eating chicken with his
family and he's like god damn you know
in his head maybe i don't believe in
jesus but [ __ ] we sure did
[ __ ] lay that dance floor flat right
okay but church isn't gonna just get
more fun
i'm saying
it's not tomorrow
they've had [ __ ] 2 000 years i don't
think it's going to get more fun any
time soon invite the [ __ ] you know
what i mean invite david gray to church
and have him do it and he's like the
[ __ ] babylon guy leave me on
hey
i mean i'd rather go to that church than
[ __ ]
what's up and ever and ever yeah that
[ __ ] is so whacked yeah i mean if he's
catholic he's [ __ ] so don't tell your
parents if they're 80 if they're 40 tell
them and then repair it that's my advice
yeah but still when you tell i think you
got to tell him i think you got to tell
him full stop i think you got to tell
him keep going okay i think you got it i
think you got to tell him
and that's it
but dude
see that's good okay all right anyway
wow hey how's it going chris and matt um
today i'm i want to ask you guys about
two of my friends who just recently uh
joined a frat um and they're going
through the pledging process and um you
know joining fras just uh dumb [ __ ]
i just want to get your guys input on on
what to do because i i see them a lot
less and less and they are changing so
how do i how do i sort of wake them up
out of this uh natty light sort of haze
that they're going through and then what
are some things i can do to get my
friends back it's it's like they got a
girlfriend and
and um yeah yeah they're both just sort
of out for the count thank you guys um
and yeah i appreciate it all of it have
a good one
oh my god the end that was the sickest
thing i had
it was like a butthead move
uh i think that
um
rats suck yeah they do suck but it's
hard though i guess if you're in college
and you feel like you're not here's the
thing frats weed out the people who are
weak if you need a group to tell you
you're good and accepted you are weaker
than someone who doesn't period so this
guy is stronger than his friend and
honestly it's not even necessarily that
he's realizing his friends don't need
him as much because they're with their
new tribe his enemies are being exposed
and i think that sometimes if you can't
beat him join them so start your own
frat dude start your own frat and call
it absolutely nunca or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it i was with you until
nunca it means i think it means nothing
in spanish it does it does yeah there
you go absolutely
absolutely nothing absolutely nunca
that's pretty good yeah dude and be like
here at absolutely nunca we [ __ ] do
not have a frat but come on over here if
you're not in a frat and we'll kind of
secretly start our own frat but we don't
have any rules and you can do whatever
you want you can live wherever you want
to but this guy's not considering
joining a frat himself no he's not he's
just annoyed or upset or frustrated that
his other friends have and they're
starting to change yeah
he's asking how can i get my friends
back i tell you right now you can't
um they're gone
you you know what how did how do you get
your friends back
they're gone you can't how do you get
friends back just get some new ones get
new ones that aren't in france you can't
be in [ __ ]
no yeah i mean like i said it's kind of
like being in a religion it's like a
little mini culture that everybody's
just sort of okay with that at college
and you know what dude they're way more
fun than church right they do a lot dude
honestly maybe not hanging upside down
maybe i'd rather be a church than a
[ __ ] frat person yeah well i would
for sure yeah no frat parties are not
baptize me place to be yeah baptize me
before you [ __ ] hang me upside down
over a [ __ ] beer uh yeah what do you
call it beer uh what do you call them
the things you hang out upside down and
keg stand
never knew it cause never was a part of
it yeah well good for you but
you need more friends this is a good
thing for you dude this is a good thing
it's also just part of like he looks
like he's around the age where you start
to lose some friends and gain new ones
because you're not a kid anymore totally
you're becoming an adult you will make
new friends i do know what it's like to
be like man i'm kind of growing away
from my old friends and before you've
made new good friends but i promise you
yeah you will make new friends and they
will be
better friends especially when you think
back on the [ __ ] guys who are in a
front you're like oh my god thank god i
didn't need to be friends with those
[ __ ] frat guys totally you lose
friends two times in your life once when
you leave high school and you get to be
in college right and another time is
like when you turn 40 and all your
friends backstab you
so you want to do the next one i guess
three times also when you die you lose
all your friends yeah you do do it but
maybe you join all your friends in
heaven that were your friends who died
early
okay
next one
hi chris and matt is taylor i'm from
toronto canada
and i am graduating from university this
year we are having a graduation ceremony
at the university this summer but i
don't really want to go because it's
just going to be full of [ __ ]
speakers and people pretending that they
care about our future
and it's just going to be super long
yeah so that's why i don't want to go
don't go but my parents really want me
to go they haven't said it but i can
kind of tell when i tell them i don't
want to go they get a little upset
so do i just go and make them happy
or do i just stick to what i want to do
and tell them that i'm not doing it
thanks for your help
they want her to go they want her to go
to her own graduate was it the
graduation she's asking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah they why do her parents want
her to go she doesn't get that i don't
do because parents care about like
ceremony and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] man it
is old school but that's what she's
dealing with you know what she's calling
in any ceremony sucks any awards show
sucks
any kind of thing where
you have to join or volunteer it all
sucks just be you dude be you your
parents should understand that you need
to be you and if you don't want to go to
your graduation then don't go to your
graduation man i don't know your
graduation i have another perspective
okay it's wrong but okay
her
i don't know do we know if it's college
or high school oh i guess so we don't
know yeah
either way if your parents [ __ ] paid
like they get nothing for all the money
that they've spent that is your [ __ ]
ungrateful especially now these times
you're not grateful but like in these
times all it is is [ __ ] three hours
of time suck
and it's gonna make them [ __ ] happy
maybe
just [ __ ] do it and bite the bullet
you know what i mean
because like
they might have spent [ __ ] 200 grand
on that [ __ ] yeah god they shouldn't
have huh no they should not have done
that but that's on them you know what
maybe you're right maybe just don't go
because that's on them and they
shouldn't spend yeah but also i get what
she's saying it's it's actually adorable
that she even like is thinking about
should i go for my parents because most
i feel like a lot of people would be
like [ __ ] them [ __ ] my parents she
obviously has a good relationship with
her parents right
it really seems like it yeah just with
the way she's talking about it yeah you
know i guess we don't know but um yeah i
think that uh i i hate
especially the ceremony dude because
everyone gives a speech and it's always
like this
and the greater times in the future yeah
but we haven't seen anna yet they don't
ever [ __ ] talk like listen guys we're
all out here and this is not about it
yeah you gotta jazz it up dude you're
just scattered i know yeah i do
but i understand why she doesn't want to
sit there with these boring [ __ ]
and then of course sings it's so hard
to say goodbye no it's not dude
or that [ __ ] green day song
remember that one uh uh the time of your
life or whatever yeah they always make
like an acapella version of yeah yeah
yeah yeah
something i'm planning on
and then the end is right
help you out that's why they do it
because this is i hope you had the time
of your life so many [ __ ] different
notes in the time dude what they should
do is [ __ ] have this song
and then you get the diploma and you're
out dude you do a spin move and you
[ __ ] moonwalk out of there dude i
skipped my college graduation did you oh
wait you didn't [ __ ] graduate next
one oh yeah that's why they didn't do it
slam a [ __ ] utter summer solstice
all right dude
hey chris hey matt
um i guess my lifeline advice is
dating as a shorter male i know how
chris feels about it i kind of want to
get like matt's take as well bro um i
know if you're below five eight or five
nine eight too small
um but i guess it always kind of
confused me a little bit how people kind
of like crap on short people like [ __ ]
on short people and
and like you're not allowed to make fun
of like overweight people but that's
something that they can possibly change
but i can't change my height yeah i
don't know i mean my last girlfriend was
six foot and i know you're thinking i
mean it worked you know i got it looks
like she wanted he's got a huge [ __ ] oh
oh my god he said it he's glad he might
go
but he had to bring it up oh
um
but yeah i guess my lifeline advice is
just basically
dating as a shorter guy and like where
to get that confidence
dude he's he's a shorter guy and he was
dating a six-foot
also he has confidence i could tell by
the way yeah dude no wonder he's got
[ __ ] he's good he's got huge [ __ ]
syndrome probably okay well relax but
dude how [ __ ] awesome would it be if
you're a short guy honestly this is the
advice own it yeah that's own it get
some sunglasses on get a [ __ ] iced
out chain that says short and
yeah dude and own it and when you go out
with your girl you make her drive and
then when you get out of the car you get
up on her like a koala and you [ __ ]
go into the restaurant and she walks in
and he's just like this with his
sunglasses and the thing that says short
bro that guy gets the most [ __ ] man you
own it is right hey and then walking by
people the mater d in the [ __ ]
restaurant so sue me i'm a koala do that
dude are you kidding me
not only
i mean
i think you were right at first
no dude you were onto something with own
it the koala thing i think he could skip
honestly that chick if she takes you to
a restaurant
you'll be leaving
you'll be walking into a restaurant with
the
with the second hottest chick because
you'll be walking out with the hottest
dude what because
he has his pick dude he walks in with
that much confidence oh i see what
you're saying and he goes like this
dude somebody once asked me if i had a
big dick or not
during dinner say it loud enough so
people would hear
bro that guy do this yeah dude oh he's
gonna binge think dude i mean that that
guy first of all he has confidence i
mean bob does you could tell he's behind
him he was [ __ ] good dude there was a
poster in fro with a guy in front of
american flag going like reading a guy
that was leonardo dicaprio that was
theoretical yes dude in yes in a wolf of
wall street it is yes
it looks like the guy from
it is yes
yes
that's not leonardo dicaprio what the
[ __ ] what more do you want that's a it's
a mexican leonardo dicaprio no no it no
it's not bro is that leonardo dicaprio
it doesn't look like they don't care to
me at all i don't think it is oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ] you why do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude wait okay okay fair
enough it's a famous [ __ ] gift too
the [ __ ] [ __ ] from [ __ ] wolf of
wall street i don't look it up
i don't see it at all look it up i don't
see it at all number two
i've never seen a face that doesn't look
like somebody more than that look like
the internet dicaprio look it up
well i suppose i deserve it because i
was doing this it's a crazy thing but
look it up
zoom that in you don't need to it's him
okay that looks like him because it is
the guy obviously because they are all
him that's an insane thing to have on
your wall but he's got confidence dude
that doesn't look that looks a little
bit like that's a bad painting how about
that it's from the [ __ ] movie it's a
picture and it doesn't matter if it
looks like him it is him okay well
it doesn't look like him more in one
place than another it's the same picture
okay this makes me wanna that's a
[ __ ] that is a horrible
representation of of a very handsome
[ __ ] lead actor named leonardo
dicaprio it doesn't look like him at all
does any of that matter beside
what matters is is it him it is yes it's
supposed to be him how about that no it
is him but here's the other thing you
thought you if if you didn't know that
that was a gif or a [ __ ] thing from
the movie you wouldn't know that that
was i think i would have you know why
because i have a brain okay well you
have a brain but it's bad but it works
and that's why i recognize who that
holds up the [ __ ] poster frail teen
frailty the movie poster frailty
pull up the movie poster frailty i've
always had this [ __ ]
i was never sure
click on that
who's that on the upper right
that's it
i mean honestly it looks like josh lucas
but i know it's not there you go is it
is it mcconaughey yep oh it doesn't look
like him does it
no not at all and you'll see joshua
because it said above matthew oh because
you know what that looks like he's in
that movie with bill paxton uh oh so you
know the movie bill paxton i think maybe
film dork she filmed i do know that
movie yeah yeah that doesn't look like
matthew kind of at all no it really
doesn't it really does if you have
magical kind of in your [ __ ] movie
definitely make sure everyone knows this
matthew mcconaughey correct yeah as a
matter of fact you should have all right
all right all right and quote under that
on every movie you know who that looks
like that [ __ ] guy
from what's his name from uh all i know
the only movie that i know he's in is uh
oh [ __ ] what is a guy josh lucas i'm
assuming because that's who i'm saying
no josh lucas dude it does look a little
bit like josh lucas honestly who do you
think it looks no it looks like um
[ __ ] i don't know the guy's name oh he
was in the show numbers remember that
show numbers
rob morrow no not him the other guy i
don't know look up numbers
look up numbers and the thing is do it
fast david krumholz yep david chrome
holds that's what it looks like david
crumholtz well googled numbers and
numbers came up what a [ __ ] idiot
number's posted and that's what that one
wow dude you know you don't think that
looks like david crumholtz
do a side by side it's a tv show
everybody said movie which is upsetting
yeah i said i said tv show right he's
searched for his movie though so it's
just dude
it was a messed up show that was on for
[ __ ] three there's david come home
look that looks so much like for the
frailty poster a little bit
doesn't it a little bit british the way
i said it but it's true
wow that was bad that looks so much like
i'm on the left that that looks like a
dude i win at that i win at that you
lose at every look-alike thing because
you didn't know who the most famous man
on [ __ ] earth is
based on the picture of his [ __ ] face
jesus christ
no no leonardo dicaprio is more famous
you're going to have christ don't know
how leonardo dicaprio's more famous than
jesus christ
well actually yeah we've got we've got a
lot of really good advice so far how
many people did we do so far
we've done a lot we actually ran out and
i need to like get more amazing dude we
could just [ __ ] talk about this dude
i got some advice for you for me uh yeah
dude oh
no you should give me um the hoodie
it sucks i would rock it uh that does
suck because you're never gonna [ __ ]
get it because it's mine
invoke
never gonna get it never gonna get it
dude did you like that [ __ ] song when
we were kids i loved the song did you
add the tape
yeah whoa i thought that was a [ __ ]
cd thing
no dude it's a i had it on tape i had it
after you um
really
what do you remember your first [ __ ]
cd or tape i remember my first cd you
got it for me it was a green day yeah it
was i got it for you dookie yeah yeah
hump your hand in time of your online
not the right album but yeah well it was
dookie dookie yeah worst album title no
way so cool that's gonna be my
autobiography dookie i did it dookie i
did it dookie it's great it didn't so
what was that one from that was basket
case
basket
dookie was the one with all the good
[ __ ] on really yeah yeah that was like
back when he was [ __ ] cool
rang the wine was it that one no that's
when i whine
[ __ ] that goes
here we go that's a marine stew that's
what it's called brain stew
brainstorming wow slate it the [ __ ] down
stew yeah wait is that from uh dookie
nope nope
well
so uh my first you know what my first cd
was uh let me guess uh i could sing
tupac no no no no no that was [ __ ]
what was i 16 when i got my first cd
that was it was 1996 when i was it i got
i guess tupac was 92 kind of when you
know yeah i guess it could have been 12
but no no mine was i was i was
10 and it was [ __ ]
boys to man what's going on
the original [ __ ] like the motown philly
yeah wow
yeah god i miss my calling you know how
mom thinks i should be a [ __ ] singer
my mama always thinks i should have i
can't sing any notes around her even as
a joke she'll be like you know what
chris you really can't you you really
should have been you know what i always
wanted to tell her too when she says
that you're wrong mom
dude how about this
when i was what 20 mom mom used to this
is so this is actually embarrassing mom
would say that i looked like josh
duhamel yeah you remember right
well i don't even remember because she
still says it yeah i think it's become a
joke like i [ __ ] so don't look like
him yeah it's unbelievable you don't
look anything like him dude he came to
my show the other day at the laugh
factory and he showed up and i i forgot
what he looks like dude no i didn't
forget what he looks like but i forgot
how handsome he was bro this guy makes
me look like [ __ ]
uh who's the guy from lord of the rings
from my precious that guy any of them
everyone's gonna call him gollum call
him dude it's unbelievable
is the most handsome guy in the world
still
better really you know guys get older
and it's [ __ ] insane how good they
look yeah it's insane and until they get
to be like 70 something and then they
start kind of deteriorating yeah yeah
but this guy [ __ ]
you wanna do another video let's go to
another video
it's unbelievable how [ __ ]
good-looking the guy is and he's even
better this guy's kind of killing it
he's good-looking yeah
hey guys love the new podcast i'm glad
matt is here to keep chris in check
because as much as i love
congratulations
let's be honest we sometimes get lost in
the sauce
so i met this girl we're both crazy in
love but she's a nurse in a native
community in a nordic village in quebec
so she's basically only here in montreal
for half of the year
we had an open relationship and we're
managing it well but we recently decided
to be exclusive
so i was wondering what do you guys
think about open relationships can it
really work long term
chris i can't wait till you get back to
montreal and i'm curious to hear you
guys opinion have a good one thanks that
guy hit one note and his whole fat guy
sounds like he was drowning so that's
sexy though for real i think that guy's
[ __ ] sexy yeah i mean i would he's a
cool now you're jealous well i'm not
jealous i think that you're shrugged and
you're like well he's not as sexy as me
but no i think that you're just you're
falling victim to he's got an accent
yeah maybe but i think he kind of looked
like robert pattinson too though he's
sexy bro
he doesn't look anything like that i
think we need to trust me on who people
look like more because you didn't even
know the [ __ ] leonardo dicaprio two out
of three people didn't know that that
was interrupted well guess what i was
right okay well but sometimes you could
not look like yourself right but i was
right do you ever see colin farrell in
the batman he doesn't look like himself
because he's got prosthetic and [ __ ]
makeup on so that guy's handsome and
sexy period have you been in open
relationships no i have been in open
relationships and it's just very hard to
navigate dude it's not easy and he was
in an open relationship and now he's not
with the girl i think that that's
i think that's progress i think that if
you start with an op
with a non-open relationship exclusive
and then go open i don't think that
that's progress i think that's whatever
the opposite yeah right right um but but
you can have a successful open
relationship i suppose but you
definitely need to have clear
rules and only go by these rules you
can't stray from these rules right yeah
you can't be like okay
you you can be like look these are the
rules don't date anybody i know don't do
the horizontal mamba with anybody i know
don't [ __ ] you could have throw out a
weird rule i don't like when you [ __ ]
with hockey players i know everyone
loves hockey into montreal steeper
but but you can say
uh but then you can't go back on that
you go back on that the whole thing is
[ __ ] there's no going back right trust
is everything right and you need to
adhere to the rules that you establish
in your relationship now everybody [ __ ]
up right i've [ __ ] up in my
relationships you know uh but
it's very very hard to go from exclusive
to open i think going from open to exclu
exclusive is is progress and that is uh
yeah you maybe you're growing up dude
you're becoming an adult you know yeah
but a guy like that with that accent is
always going to cheat anyway next no
he's always going to have [ __ ] plenty
of women he can be with right right
right right i mean he's
i would [ __ ] want to date that guy
but that being said is he i i'm not sure
i was too like
uh mystified and mesmerized by him was
he saying he's considering about going
back to an open relationship i don't
think so i just think that he was asking
do you think open relationships could
work i would i have never and would
never try one yeah i know people who are
in them and happy and
i i have to believe them because they're
saying it and i i don't know better than
someone else's brain i do not i do know
rather that i would never
do that or want to do that or could do
that period [ __ ] full stop and why
would you never do that couldn't
couldn't you know what else worth the
reason i don't want to i don't want to
oh interesting you have no desire no i
mean if i have a partner
that's the partner i want yeah and that
i don't i think it's the way i think of
it like i don't
if i'm with someone that is the person i
want to be with
and so having an open relationship i
don't even like part of me doesn't
really quite get it well
you know
thank god you're not an animal you know
what i mean like an actual animal like
you know penguin not a penguin penguins
or monogamous you know what i [ __ ]
read about penguins all look like each
other you know what i read about
penguins the other day this is real
they [ __ ] dead penguins
because the way uh sometimes penguins
will die in the position of the way that
they position themselves when they're
asking to be mated with and then a male
penguin will go up to a dead female
penguin and [ __ ] it
i mean don't shoot the messenger
[ __ ] a dead
yup dude hey
nature
figure that out yeah well dude the [ __ ]
it's a loophole dude how about how
[ __ ] penguins just dying like this
that's yeah just just with a [ __ ] log
in its mouth with the fins like this
horny penguins coming by
i wonder what that position really is
though penguin style unfortunate
unfortunate
an unfortunate way to pass just passing
like this like
on the side and then the [ __ ] another
living penguin walks up and then go
right next to it and behind it doing it
doing the [ __ ] lazy republican behind
it like this
the lazy republican yeah that's what
that um
that's the position i don't know i made
it you literally right now made it up
it's called the lazy republican for me
and what is it where you're like this
on your side the the person your mate if
it's a chick or a dude if it's gay sex
whatever but like the other person is in
front of you and you're behind them and
you're just kind of like it's doggy
style but laying down on it and why are
you a republican
you know what i mean because because
you're republican because it's like you
think you're doing something dirty but
really you're just you're not because
when you do it you don't believe in
climate change no no no it's less than
that and more like ooh this is crazy
honestly republicans are the new punk
rock so i i made it
unfortunately yeah yeah i made it i made
it
i made it back when republicans were
like oh we don't do that kind of they
are still that don't [ __ ] be full
okay when when it comes to when it comes
to the older republicans yes but the new
republicans dude don't be fooled they
still like [ __ ] believe in god no i
know but they they would [ __ ] i mean
they they're gonna have like the new
[ __ ] woodstock soon get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here with who just kid rock
i am kidding oh dude
with red ties on in woodstock 1999
whatever year it was kid rock has the
[ __ ] best [ __ ] oh yeah that's right
what is it again it's uh it's uh
you want me to get political
oh yeah monica lewinsky is a hoe and
bill clinton's a [ __ ] pia so not
political
the worst political take [ __ ] ever
it's one of my favorite videos play can
you play it
that was on the schedule but yeah so i
didn't want but dude he has to pull up
stuff that we want to because it's fun
and we're talking about it yeah
that's so shitty of chris rock to do
that but also
here it is this is it again political cr
worst contract impression okay here we
well this is go as deep as kid rock
thinks
monica lewinsky is a [ __ ] hoe and
bill clinton is a goddamn pill
well the way he's yep so serious after
unbelievable that's what you see of
people just like he made the greatest
[ __ ] point god how many people are
there and
my favorite
what did he say in the beginning listen
up
uh this is as deep as do you want me to
get political this is deep before that
he was like listen closely or something
which was great he did something like
listen closely which is like you don't
need to yeah i mean i missed that part
but yeah
chris chris stop doing that you know
what i mean i don't know man you know
what i mean but i think that that's very
political dude and i think that that's
great that he's speaking his mind yeah i
think it's great he's being political he
loves [ __ ] trump so now he does look
for him back then but he said bill
clinton is a pimp
so he kind of just loves men in charge
right you know what that's what it is
yeah yep um so you think
what was the [ __ ] advice thing we
were talking about are the penguins oh
you told me about penguins but why do we
start talking about open relationships
open relationships right i think that um
don't do it just yeah well don't do it
but but uh we've evolved over the
[ __ ] years
in a way that it didn't prep us for that
[ __ ] and it's nobody's fault it's not
our fault but we're not ready for that
[ __ ] it's not how we do it
if you insist like i said there are
people who even that i know that do it
and they're happy but dude i don't call
me [ __ ] old-fashioned i do not get it
and i do not want it either
i think it can work um i think it's very
uh i need you need to have
serious delineations and lines and uh
adhere to them and um
if you have any questions about what you
should or shouldn't do you have to refer
to your partner first
um i just think it's a lot of work you
know it sounds like it and uh it [ __ ]
sounds like it i guess it could work but
if you are open this is my advice to
this guy if you're open and then you
went to
exclusive there's no going back
you that's a progression right so that's
definitely don't go back that's the
question do not do that yeah imagine
them having sex with just themselves in
the middle are like man we gotta go back
to being open yeah yeah that's crazy
about penguins they shouldn't [ __ ] dead
penguins huh the guy that discovered
that that was true
hid the discovery because he thought it
was so [ __ ] up which is like so
no it was just like it was so long ago
it was so long ago yeah
stop saying what i said what you're
saying yeah no but now now it would be
[ __ ] literally uh on on every article
and it'd be like hey guess what penguins
[ __ ] deads
deads necrophiliacs yeah penguins are
necrophiliacs i knew that word you
didn't i know what it means
well now you do mm-hmm
having sex with
necro wafers
oh you're doing another one or what are
we doing nah that's good i think i'm
good yeah um you guys this has been
great phoenix arizona i'm gonna be in
your city february 30th you can go to
crystallia.com to get tickets i'm also
doing uh
april 27th at the hollywood improv
christolia.com and uh i'm putting out
more dates uh be ready in the first week
of may i'm gonna be pumping out dates
for uh other um
cities on the on the east coast and
different cities and then um also listen
to congratulations
and uh we got to start your podcast up
soon but um that's about that like and
subscribe to this channel and activate
that algorithm
make friends in the comments that's how
we do it and also feel free to give
advice to any of the people that gave
videos into this show uh in the comments
section and we'll like uh go in there
and pin some of them or whatever we
might not but we might we might not so
anyway we appreciate you is that it
yeah if you want to submit there's a
link in the description below also want
more specific questions we'd love that
more specific questions what do you mean
by that just
right now they've been very general oh
they've been general yeah they have been
general i have noticed that actually get
specific with it baby ask
submit
ask what you need to ask don't be afraid
to be specific yes okay cool very good i
love specificity you know that you know
me right okay you know i don't make it
about you no i know but people like it
right i understand but
it's you know it's not like your thing
that you like specifically this is our
show it's 51 my show and no i don't know
fifty point one percent my show all
right uh thanks guys thanks for
listening like and subscribe bye-bye
hello